Shark pack,
I need your help.
It's time for a shark food
taste test!
That's a no to pickles,
no to chorizo,
no to mac and cheese
and a no
to the meatball sub.
Not fish sticks!
I propose we take a
different approach to food.
I made this with
my molecular gastronomy kit.
-Huh?
-Your what?
Molecular gastronomy.
It's like cooking
with chemistry.
This tiny cube tastes just
like a rotisserie chicken.
It'll be irresistible!
Not fish sticks.
Wow, considering sharks will
eat pretty much anything,
he's really picky.
Don't give up!
We have one last dish
to try: brussels sprouts.
Ew!
No one likes
brussels sprouts.
I guess this taste test
is as good as over.
Ooh!
He… likes them?
Like them?
I think this is love!
More, more, more!
Bam, he loves it!
Where'd you get them?
From the mega planet
of Brusseltron!
Just kidding!
I got them from Mr. Hughball
down at the farmers' market.
He's a real sprout head
nowadays.
Oh, that must be why
his garden's so stinky.
Sprouts, sprouts, sprouts!
Wow, sprouts. We did it!
And brussels sprouts are
so cheap,
we can buy a ton
with our money, right?
Our money?
Oh, fine.
My problems are solved!
Goodbye fish sticks,
hello brussels sprouts.
Oops!
That's the last of them,
Sharkdog.
Don't worry, bud.
I'll head
to Mr. Hughball's stall
to get more sprouts
first thing in the morning.
-Goodnight.
-Night, Max.
Sprouts, sprouts!
Yeah!
Sprouts!
Sprouts, sprouts, sprouts!
Sprouts.
Yum!
Intruder alert!
-Intruder alert?
-Intruder alert.
My beautiful,
itty-bitty brussels?
Must be
that blasted raccoon again!
Hey, raccoon!
Who's got two thumbs
and is coming for you?
This guy!
Where are you?
Oh, there you are,
you little…
Got you! Over here.
No, over here.
I can hear you, raccoon!
My beautiful big brussels!
Oh, I've had it, raccoon!
This is your
sprout-pocalypse.
Aha!
Ah!
No!
What was that?
Got you!
Uh oh.
End of the line, raccoon.
Yeah!
What? Wh…
Where'd you go?
Time to go!
Mummy…
Uh oh.
Sharkdog?
-Oh, honey!
-It wasn't me!
Max?
Hi, mum. Hi, dad.
What is that awful smell?
Why am I suddenly craving
brussels sprouts?
My chemistry
cooking experiment failed.
Well, exploded.
It's called…
mamarnotoponis
glopontopomi.
It's the newest thing
for chefs like me.
At this time of night?
Huh?
Sorry about all this.
I guess I just wanted
a midnight snack.
Well, at least
I'm glad to see you
finally eating
something other than fish.
Alright.
Bed now! Clean up tomorrow.